what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are gonna watch today
the official trailer for The Last of Us this
is my best Joel cosplay equipped together at
the last minute join with me is one of
my best friends someone one of the first
people who really heavily encouraged me to
play The Last of Us and I played this game
twice since then played the second one twice
since then Andrew Gordon how are you Andrew
I'm doing great dude that cosplay is sick I I
actually almost said hey what's up Joel when
I walked in here so I mean you were killing
it with that I appreciate that this is good
rapport we are developing on camera together
I am so excited for this ladies and Gentlemen
please leave a like uh we are planning of
course uncovering this show right here on
this very Channel because I I am so jazzed that
there's been a lot of big trailers this week any
little extra bit we can get of this outweighs
any trailer we've seen all right let's go
[Music]
if you don't think there's hope for
the world oh my God damn it looks so
much like the game yeah we haven't seen
the world flickers so you don't know
keep going for family
yeah no your cargo I love the music
it's almost the fact that I didn't turn
into a monster I see so much twitches
definitely your personality yeah
oh this song oh I remember
that point yeah Henry and Sam
you got any advice on the best way west
you've come this far the northern
lights and you know what's out there
they hear based on sounds scared who [Applause]
[Music] I don't know who those guys are
I must be yeah Marlene is that Ashley Johnson
I think so be careful who you put your feet
your father true songs yeah
David yeah it's Gotta Be
we didn't see him on the casting list we
were looking it up beforehand yeah we did oh
that was amazing so good that loader holy
crap that was great oh my God [__] that
effects looks insanely accurate oh my God
it's scary that's really scary yeah I mean we
saw like a little bit of everything like look
we're just gonna talk as if you know the game
We're Not Gonna really try to explain everything
for you guys so if you guys haven't played the
game you might want to just click off right now
and that's totally fine yeah I mean we got to
see a little bit of everything here from like
pretty much the whole game it looks like in the
snowy Parts this must be the part where the like
David and the cannibal I call them David and the
cannibals but then of course there's like a bunch
of new imagery here that I don't know who this
like Native American who ordered these guys yeah
they're the who they're talking to do you have any
idea who these guys are new characters yeah it
must be new characters because they don't look
familiar to me but which I'm glad too because I
don't want this to be a specific carbon copy yeah
I want certain images yeah yeah I want obviously
the same characters and all but I do want them
to add you know new characters and offer some
new scenes as well even though the first game
is pretty much perfect yeah but I I don't want to
feel like an exact carbon copy obviously there are
things that I don't mind that they're gonna do
from the video game of course but I don't mind
that they add some layers and cut like giving
Ellie I know she had a sense of humor in the
game and she just had that commanding presence
to her and I love whenever she cusses too it's
it's one of my favorite traits of her personality
she's probably my favorite video game character I
mean and I mean look the the Crux of the the
strength of this show like in the video game
is going to be based on the the chemistry and the
relationship between Pedro Pascal and Bella Ramsay
I mean like I said I want to see a lot of if uh
stuff from the video game for sure but I'm very
curious like these new characters that we see in
other characters uh that get expanded upon and I
really think we were talking about this earlier
I think it's a great idea that they're making a
TV show rather than a film because we get to see
characters fleshed out more we get to spend more
time with these characters it would be hard to
justify everything in a two and a half hour film
with you know how new on constant How Deep The and
layered the the first video game is so I'm really
glad they made the decision and we got Ashley
Johnson right there Ashley Johnson that's cool
to get hurt in here yeah given birth during the
apocalypse yeah I believe Troy Baker 2 is going
to be in this as well he's going to have a little
bit of a cameo so to get Ashley Johnson and Troy
Baker that's cool there's glad you spotted Ashley
Johnson right there in the heat at the moment yeah
that's great it looks like he's gonna be playing
an important character actually especially because
so much of the game you know when you're doing a
survivalistic type of Apocalypse game you want to
capture the little glimmers of hope for the future
of humanity and it looks like her characters the
fact that she's giving birth is going to be in
some way a service to that you know we gotta hear
more this time of you know Pedro Pascal doing
the dialogue as Joel We got to hear more Bella
Ramsay doing the dialogue is Ellie Pedro Pascal
is absolutely killing it like they're both making
it their own it still feels like in the likeness
and hearkening to what we loved from them from the
video games but I think like what they're doing
in terms of the presence and the aura that they
bring for those roles I think they're both nailing
it I know there's been a little bit bit of a back
and forth debate over Bella Ramsey as Ellie yeah
because like you know despite the fact that Pedro
Pascal is a Latino no one seems to even notice
that when it comes to it which I think is really
cool that we're just like yeah Victor Pascal he
just the way he carries himself the body language
the presence the demeanor the delivery seems like
Joel but it's still making it his own where Bella
Ramsay I feel like she I I want to see more
of her but what I'm with the little glimpses
for getting of her I think she's doing a really
good job and I'm not distracted by it I mean and
also too like putting her on a pedestal from the
character Valley you just said she's your favorite
character it's it's hard when you're again when
you're going off a character that's so beloved
and like if you're not nailing the first look like
Optics are a very big thing before we actually see
any footage so I can understand why people were
very not sure if like just from the look if Bella
Rams is going to do a good job again just from
the little glimpses we're seeing I'm loving the
Rapport that we're seeing between her and Pedro
Pascal genuinely too I love that off screen they
have such a like for each other you know it's such
an again the relationship to me is so endearing it
really compares to me to Ellen Ripley and new to
the Terminator and John Connor so I just I see
so many similarities and nuances there so this
is really a tough and really deep relationship
that really has to be nailed down so again I
can understand people's not being negative but
just maybe having just some like hey not sure
about his this she doesn't nail the look of
this like Ashley Johnson just nailed that voice
down so I can understand but so far just from
everything we're seeing chemistry-wise off screen
and on screen I'm really liking what we're seeing
and obviously again to me that's going to be the
biggest strength of the show is their relationship
I mean obviously I love all the other characters
from the video game but that's where the strength
of the show is going to rely on something to me
feels like because you know I think what they're
doing with this show is I think they're probably
going to divide this the storyline of the first
season uh I I feel like they're probably going to
cut it off at after David is killed and that will
be the end of season one yeah where they set off
to go to the Firefly Camp something tells me that
that's where they're going to end in Spanish yeah
I mean it would be because that is such a crucial
turning point for both those characters in that
moment you know especially for um uh Ellie you
know when she like gets her revenge and murders
this guy I think that would be it and then you
could do an expander because this looks like an
extended version of the game in a lot of ways I
mean so much with Bill we didn't get to see Frank
and we just alluded to Frank in the first game
this time looks like we're gonna see part of their
friendship it seemed like in the game that they
might have been like lovers or something like yeah
that's that's what I thought too but that's why I
love that they're going with the TV show stuff we
didn't see like the Frank that you just mentioned
in Bill storyline like we only got a little bit
of Bill in the game and I love W Earl Brown who
of course was the camera guy Courtney Cox's camera
guy in Scream one I'm glad that uh we're getting
gonna get more of Bill and uh his play by Nick
Offerman in this uh show and the Frank storyline
because I was actually I know that was not a very
big thing in the first video game but it was still
as impactful yeah it was impactful I'm like I want
to see I want to see more about it so yeah and I'm
glad too that we saw in the the IMDb cast list
we saw that Riley is going to be yeah there's a
little glimpse of her here yeah so yeah so I'm
glad I thought that was really cool that they
included that in the video game you could play a
prequel to the events that led up to the start of
the first game so I'm really excited to see that
because that that prequel is so freaking awesome
it's not very long or anything but it's freaking
awesome yeah and I'm really glad that we got Merle
Dan uh Dandridge back as uh Marlene yeah because
obviously she voiced her in the game so it's
really cool they got Ashley Johnson they got Merle
Dandridge they got Jeffrey Pierce who voiced Tommy
Miller Joel's brother Tommy he's going to be in
this show as well he's playing a character named
Perry I believe is what it said it's really cool
and then they got the composer Gustavo from the
first two uh games oh that music the western
music so I'm just excited guys what did you
think about this trailer leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave a like
click that Bell uh keep a lookout when we cover
this show follow Andrew on Twitter igor711 on
Instagram we'll catch you all soon thanks Andrew
for being here thank you all for being [Music]